joining me on the show this week is
author speaker and associate director of
the Henry Jackson society Douglas Mari
I've been familiar with Douglases work
for almost a year now his name kept
popping up in my twitter feed after the
Charlie Hebdo shootings like last week's
guest ayaan Hirsi Ali Douglas has been a
relentless defender of free speech even
when it isn't popular to do so part of
my awakening about the regressive left
came around the same time as Charlie
Hebdo when I saw more concern for
political correctness than for the
victims of the horrific attack I was
really impressed with Douglases clean
and clear explanation of why free speech
must be protected at all costs and
that's one of the issues we're going to
talk about today this is where I should
tell you the Douglas Murray is a neocon
the word neocon sounds kind of evil to
me sort of like a Decepticon and like
Decepticons neo cons are big on world
domination or are they well that's what
we're going to find out when we talk to
Douglas today you know we get so lost in
throwing around labels all the time that
we hardly know what they mean anymore as
I understand it a neocon is someone who
wants to spread democracy through
military intervention and we all know
how well that usually works out right
well this is just generally thought of
in the American lens but is it the same
for the British I want to find that out
and my way off altogether I want to find
that out too and that's what we're going
to talk about some of you might be
thinking Dave you've been labeling the
regressive left for weeks now how is
that different than labeling someone a
neocon I think the thing is here that we
had to identify what the regressive left
stands for so that we could also
identify what we stand for as I've said
before I felt the need to talk about the
lunacy on the left because there's just
weren't enough voice is amplifying the
battle of ideas that you guys all want
to have that's why you're here and
that's what I'm going to continue to do
so today as I sit here with someone
firmly on the right a scary
neoconservative let's all have a battle
of ideas and actually listen to what he
says and then formulate opinions on
those ideas let's not do what the
regressive left does which is label
someone and then prejudge everything
they say based on that very label I
think there's going to be agreement
disagreement and everything in between
and it's our ability to have those
his conversations and know that people
we disagree with can feel as just and as
principled as we do that's the spirit
that I'll continue to do this show in
well i do want to continue having these
types of conversations i also want to
assure you guys that we're going to be
widening the net around here as well I
want to talk politics science culture
and more of course free speech and the
battle of ideas will always be a
mainstay but I don't want to become a
one-trick pony either next week I have
two people who are putting many of the
ideas we've been talking about into
action david keys and faisal al mutare
from advancing human rights org they're
using the tools of democracy to help
advance human rights in parts of the
world where the people are most affected
by the ideas we've been talking about
the point is I'm going to keep mixing it
up keep letting me know what you guys
think and who you want me to talk to
most importantly let's keep pushing the
conversation forward so we can build
bridges where others would just tear
them down
you